glenn beck a self-described
constitutionalist radio host former Fox
News host and the founder of the website
that gave Tommy lehren a platform is not
the name most Americans were expecting
to see post-election as the antidote to
the shock but here we are somehow he's
become the voice of reason because he's
calling for unity now Beck has been
saying some of the right things for
instance before the election he said he
had empathy for black lives matter as
should other conservatives many of the
people who are marching that are not
burning things down they just want to be
heard and we're saying all lives matter
and he's consistently been critical of
Donald Trump has people chanting put
them in jail put them in jail about the
press when is someone's opinion on a
public figure something that is jail
worthy and not First Amendment protected
bill this guy is a nightmare he is so
under educated on the issues he is a
danger to the Republican in fact a month
before the election Beck actually said
that defeating Trump was the moral and
ethical thing to do even if that meant
voting for Hillary Clinton he's even
denounced bry power editor Steve benen
Trump's chief strategist not for being a
white nationalist but forgiving a
platform for some here's a guy who is
taking his platform and saying I'm going
to give the all right a voice in this
country and in a recent op-ed in the New
York Times Beck even said that if there
was a Muslim registry he'd get up and
say I am a Muslim but before jumping
onto the beck is a voice of reason
bandwagon let's get a nice dose of
perspective take for instance Glenn
Beck's criticism of Trump which is
heavily rooted in his criticism of
progressives and socialism because I
think he has socialist tendencies he
believes in big government I believe
that Donald Trump is progressive in
nature he he looks for the strong
government Beck's guy for the record was
extreme right-wing candidate
Ted Cruz Glenn Beck also said he'll
stand against the unconstitutional
Muslim registry but he's the guy who
wrote this book and has this to say
following the 2016 Brussels attack I'm
tired of hearing people say that this is
radical Islam no it's not this is
traditional Islam and while he said he
wouldn't give someone like Steve benen a
platform he totally was cool giving
platforms to people like Islamophobic
conspiracy theorists Frank asked me and
for years spreading misinformation about
creeping sharia glenn beck also played a
crucial role in setting the stage for a
trump presidency after all before make
America great again we had restoring
honor and the Tea Party both thanks to
beck and let's not forget Beck's
prediction of the impending destruction
of the United States through that
socialist Marxist communist racist
President Barack Obama once mr.
president once deny Marxism communism
revolutionaries tell us you are against
all of this this president I think has
exposed himself as a guy over and over
and over again who has a deep-seated
hatred for white people or the white
culture I don't know what it is in a
recent interview with The New Yorker beg
did say that he made some mistakes about
Obama who made him quote a better man
he's also said that other Americans
should learn from his mistakes and try
to unite the country not further divide
it but how much unity and reason should
we expect from someone who's built his
career setting the stage for president
elect Donald Trump
[Music]